we thought things couldn't get any
wilder after seeing three generations of
spider-man join forces but it turns out
original spidey director sam raimi might
have just what the doctor ordered as a
follow-up marvel's next big movie dr
strange in the multiverse of madness has
finally been previewed by critics and
the reaction suggests that the sequel is
bringing some major changes to the mcu
all thanks to two eagerly anticipated
players in this reality bending
blockbuster following the events of
spider-man no way home master of the
mystic guard steven strange has to clear
up the mess he made after tearing the
multiverse a new one unable to handle
things on his own he crosses paths with
former avenger and super spell caster
scarlet witch who could hinder as much
as help in stranger's mission to set
things right with different dimensions
visited and major marvel comics legends
potentially making an appearance it
sounds like multiverse of madness has a
lot to offer however the biggest draw
according to critics isn't the doctor
himself but the guest appearance from
the legendary wonder maximoff the pros
have reached the consensus where doctor
strange ii is concerned wanda rules and
reymi is at his best but the story
suffers from some well multiversal
madness with twitter reactions coming
thick and fast following the first
screenings for the upcoming marvel movie
one running theme is appraised for
elizabeth olsen's return as a scarlet
witch following her emmy nomination for
her work on the disney plus series one
division multiverse of madness seems to
be yet another engrossing performance
from olsen that's one of marvel's most
powerful heroes
dom fisher of geek vibes nation tweeted
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness should be called the multiverse
of maximoff as elizabeth olsen
completely steals the show multiverse of
madness marks olson's seventh appearance
in the role and derek francisco of
inverse ranks this one right at the top
of her marvelous filmography he calls it
one of the most engrossing layered
performances ever by an actor in this
genre no one has understood their
superhero on fundamental levels since
like christopher reeve as superman after
taking over from scott derrickson who
left over creative differences director
sam raimi returns to a genre he's not
visited since 2007. so how did the man
that gave us the original spider-man
trilogy handle things horrifyingly well
as it turns out when you have the
director that gave the world the
original evil dead trilogy and the
bone-chilling operation scene from
spider-man 2 let loose in the world of
doctor strange things are always
guaranteed to get a little creepy it
turns out it's a marriage of mines and
multiverses that pays off in all the
right ways with raymie sneaking in
marvel's first bout with horror
discussing films andrew j salazar says
that from snap zooms to circle wipes to
shaky cam and first person pov the
iconic visionary pulls out all the old
tricks while fully utilizing the
untapped potential of doctor strange to
further expand his visual arsenal
according to mary murs raymie is truly
all over it and the horror elements are
something special but it's so fast as
brutal and fun did not feel like
anything i've watched in the mcu before
as great as it may be to see raymie take
the reigns of a comic book movie again
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness apparently does start to buckle
under the weight of its own
interdimensional plot at least according
to critics amelia ember wing from ign
wrote the script is downright hokey
sometimes and there are odd moments that
are weird for the sake of it without
adding anything to the overall law or
character development kayla hale stern
of the mary sue pointed out similar
faults saying this movie is a mess but
messes aren't always bad it's not bad i
just don't really know what to do with
it and it feels like it should belong to
the marvel of another era not helping to
kick off a new one regardless a
consensus suggests that doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness might be
worth the trip see for yourself when the
film arrives in cinemas on may 6th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]